hey guys greg alba here gregory
alba and i'm the John the John here this
is our first video back in this reaction
roll and take a little break I wanted to
say to you guys though a lot of you have
been very supporting a lot of you guys
have been dicks too but a lot of you
guys have been very supporting as for
the dicks III we did a video called Ryan
writes last offense yeah and it was
meant to be a joke and everyone thought
that I was having a mental breakdown
about it yeah that that is the case if
that is the case I liter I'm breaking
down and I want capitalize off of my
meltdown for you guys
I'm filling for starters your meltdown
to get some new hair is my new hairstyle
for the next three videos right Oh
how are we doing are we doing that who's
my new hairstyle because I'm having
meltdown now I kind of looks the same
and uh so now when you guys go to the
thumbnail you're gonna be like this
guy's really lost his mind
yeah you look great crazy I look great
you look you look great the way like a
like a a guy who in a mug shot looks
great yeah you like that guy's crazy
probably
alright guys so we're gonna check out
the Lego Batman movie official Wayne
Manor sheet Manor teaser trailer number
two damn I like the lego movie a lot and
I love Batman totally stole the show
we'll Arnett's Batman was great I'm
really distracted by how I look right
now
and I'm trying not to be but I was like
I am you look like Tom Savini in when
he's the Hitman who's Tom Savini tell me
he's he's sex machine in the vampire
Robert Rodriguez movie from the Sun I'm
you guy was begun beanie off the hammer
you couldn't recall the title of from
Dustin I know I don't know why hello
again uber nerd fans
I heard you blew up the Twittersphere
about my sweet new feature film the Lego
Batman movie you know it's kind of like
the original lego movie only vastly
superior because it revolves
entirely around me so anyway when you're
as super as me you don't get just one
trailer you get two trailers in one week
check this out
hey mom hey Dad
I saved the city again today
I think you would have been really proud
Hey Oh Alfred I am so sorry I have
incredible reflexes I should have known
better than to sneak up on him like that
were you looking at the old family
pictures again no I wasn't sir I've seen
you go through similar phases in 2016 in
2012 and 2008 and 2005 and 1997 1995 and
1992 with 1989 and that weird one in
1966 I have aged phenomenally do you
want to talk about how you're feeling
what no I don't want to do that sir
no sir no no no no no no no no gosh I
hope we were recording that we're not
Alfred what did I say a B are always be
recording
Batman do I'll be bad 20 go win a baby
oh wait first try it who's who's behind
him um the I know the guy who's behind
it I know he directed like a lot of
Robot Chicken
oh hello interesting yeah I see the
Robot Chicken vibe I don't want in that
like the humor even the animation is
good kind of you know like the way
everything moved with the comedy bits
also a lot of it did seem very much
Robot Chicken like oh yeah they seems
like they ramped a little bit of
stop-motion style up because I mean look
first like a movie hat it but they
there's some like really glitchy moments
there which I'm genuinely excited for
this film because it's it's Batman it's
like the Batman story done in a parody
form that's still gonna look cool well
it's the only place for you to have some
fun with Batman yeah you know because
it's like as you can do all sorts of
wacky things and you can kind of rib and
be humorous yes exactly
and I think will arnett is the perfect
voice for this Batman that they have and
it is the great playground to actually
make fun of Batman I love that Warner
Brothers is doing this one too you know
and how they're having a great sense of
humor about it like Batman V Superman
just came out and they're already like
making fun of that fact what and and the
way he plays Batman is probably like the
literal joke people keep making but oh
these characters is xrz movies like he's
so into himself
yeah so serious about everything so it's
you know it's it's it's even more
relevant in how the BBS is killed and
you know like I'm excited to see it a
lot for the animation too because I like
the DC animated movies I like the
animated series and I like Tim Burton's
films too and you know I like I like
them all pretty much one thing I love is
exploring Gotham City and I feel like
this movie like they didn't really show
it but I feel like we're gonna get an
exploration of you know the lego movie
style but Gotham City style yeah you
know I'm excited to see that and then
you know you see that there's the
Justice League pretty much in here too
yeah so it's like giving us you know
like a spoof of things we've already
seen making fun of things that we're
probably gonna be never gonna be getting
next year I feel like this is actually
eight marching it just starts off with
making fun of the fact that they're
marketing it twice in one week
we're basically doing like a more
family-friendly version of like have
Deadpool advertised oh yeah it's like
you know acknowledging what they're
doing and being kind of silly about it
and you know just putting it out there
cuz it's awesome okay
I noticed Eva don't look at the camera
sorry Greg Alba Austria yeah that's
that's original it's my first
observation first Israeli first things I
thought was is he gonna do that so not
it stills I feel no I can get away with
it it's nice to see that Seth
grahame-smith is finally writing a thing
that's not like based on a hyper
specific book or you know soap opera
immediately could be nice to see him
just write a comedy doesn't really have
the best like background though in terms
of like you know the movies that have
come out grande there's a lot more than
just a screenplay to a story you know
like dark shadow much more but a
moderate effect um you know your Pride
and Prejudice and Zombies way I mean I
heard some people say that was fun and
people like the book if anything I've
heard more about the directions definite
and Warner Brothers must seem to really
like him I mean they're having new Lego
Batman we do the flash ya know without a
doubt I'm definitely gonna be watching
this movie and I hope you're there with
me me yeah I mean it's a farce like
buttery popcorn dude don't even say that
cuz I could go for some popcorn right I
could go for popcorn at any my oh he did
moral Orel to okay I'm a fan of this
director cuz like morals like off the
beaten path here like in terms of like
is pretty crazy with its humor um so I'm
excited yeah if he's involved he's done
a lot of robot shake like he's getting
this guy who's clearly used to moving
around Chris McKay sorry did I do
something wrong again are you gonna plan
something that I did wrong
I don't exploit me for awkward camera
presence no those days are behind me
you're just doing that to yourself okay
mom why do you [ __ ] if you're new to the
channel subscribe today and become a
reject and reasons to Jerry and dank ass
Stubbs is on this channel we got to
change that title the reasons to the
John reasons to the John that sounds
like a I'm going to draft like like a
mistranslated guide to using the
bathroom in some other country and
follow us on social networks like
Facebook Instagram and Twitter because
we're actually using those now yeah we
go but promoting them for a long time it
I'm actually I'm pretty consistent with
it
yeah and then the one we didn't ever
promote was by and then he stopped me
yeah